what's crackalackin umbrella academy
fans i'm greg i am errone we're gonna
watch umbrella academy season two
episode so far for the majestic 12.
i think it is a spin on the title
the seven samurai
you guys might have already heard me say
this especially by this point now but
youtube only allows for 10 minutes worth
of footage so this is qualifying as
reaction
highlights over at our patreon we'll
have the full length watch along
so you guys become a patron jack today
and
here wake up with a patreon talk we got
a weekly q a podcast
all right and then we also have plenty
of shows where we do watch alongs and
have reaction highlights for them
available at our patreon those shows are
supernatural doctor who jojo's bizarre
adventure the promised neverland
attack outside death note my hero
academia code kiosk hunter hunter one
punch man vulnerable alchemist
brotherhood violet every garden
demon slayer and then we do stream
alongs for a bunch of other shows
[Music]
1993
[Music]
holy [ __ ] oh god oh
that hazel is that yeah i think that's
hazel
she's in the vents
that's a crafty little girl oh clever
girl
oh lily's not biological mom
adopted my mom
oh lily's definitely gonna help them out
on the end oh yeah she's gonna she has
to she's gotta kill her she has to you
killed my parents prepare to die
wait 1993 oh she brought her to the 60s
but she wasn't lying she did see her
parents murdered oh wow
she straight up trained her whoa
upgrade
she there on a mission prom death
mission oh
no
[Music]
she trained a femme fatale
already
oh you liar you liar are they ever asked
to time travel back to like prehistoric
times or
like medieval times you know
oh it's just my other sister
you're not the one i [ __ ] he's an
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
how do you need your money back you're
never gonna find a fighter like him
there you you failed to are
a boatload
you could just get in the car
[Laughter]
[Music]
apparently that is how it works
[Laughter]
yeah the frog's like well what the hell
we're both gonna drown now
[Laughter]
frogs
no i can't no no he would he would have
done something about it all right that
was a majestic
toy right there
it's crazy how much like way more
compelling lily is now
[Laughter]
dad
one you could do no wrong in my eyes
[Laughter]
lava
i feel like there's something up with
her
with with her as a character [ __ ] [ __ ]
i feel like there's something up with
her like that she's part of the beer
i feel like she's got a secret like a re
like i i think she's just
way too way too there's got to be
something where she's in on the know in
some way
she's a robot she's the new
have to talk to you grace something
important you're starting to believe all
the stuff he's saying about the military
this isn't this is a bad idea
don't do this
this is not
no no david i'm gonna make him hit him
david no
david oh
no oh he got punched by you man
he didn't want to do it all fairness
class went about it in the
worst way possible oh totally like
that's not how you do that
damn that was like terrible
or close or klaus you're having a
meeting without me
got a lot of nerve shots miles jesus
miles okay guy
why is he's a cold-hearted [ __ ] right
just cause you
got a [ __ ] to save your life would be
you better have some
solid reasoning right
is now i wasn't even using the spy i
didn't say anything i saw you
i saw you whisper something oh i see now
just tell them you got powers girl she's
really ashamed of it though
yeah but the truth will set you free oh
i
think we both know no it's gonna go back
so he's been sober he's been sober no
klaus this makes me sad you can't just
do it in the store bro
it seems like a trip
the followers oh which means ben's
girl's there
did he not see the van he didn't see the
van when he walked up there
right now it's okay to wear different
clothes five
yeah i was just thinking like is he ever
gonna change his clothes
it's appropriate for this setting
he knows he's thinking of your ass
maybe a dick but he's a smart man
oh that looks shots like that that make
me regret giving up me
all right it's okay it's okay greg it's
okay it's okay okay
it's okay it's okay daddy never left you
oh what are the odds
hey my husband's just been kind of a
dick to me
sure it's not even tucked in oh i got
rooms on my hands
oh what where'd all the people go
what the [ __ ] that was a symbolic shot
oh just them
it's only them in the world symbolism
symbolism
no i'm snaps i'm good guys
[Laughter]
good weather
[Laughter]
they're not going to mention her
daughter
[Laughter]
but now that you're here i'll leave him
you just my filler man
[Laughter]
oops we did it again
all right because she hasn't seen five
yet yeah i
love luther this season i love him
luther season two much better yeah i
thought
he's so great such a great character man
where'd you go oh you smart boy
oh you sexy little liar
man oh oh well let's take a second
to have them have a sexy dance in the
show
umbrella academy's woke
she's leading you're her little puppy
[Laughter]
brother har
graves
grace no is it her oh snap mama
the real one oh there's like a flesh and
blood one
oh i think so i think that's what
they're saying but why did he take so
long to redesign
oh that guy was in the uh wasn't he in
the bar when sissy's husband was going
crazy carl
left his wallet i think that guy was in
the bar oh it's a very specific detail
to remember
i just remember being like might be
looking good that's right
suspicious mib looking dude no way the
real grace
wow nuts nuts oh
no don't do that never heard that one
before
you're a real person now that's nice
she's got that accent too edgy he's my
favorite
[Music]
larry yeah mom and dad
do you have a problem why is that weird
i i guess i guess i know it's weird hey
hi grace
it's nice meeting you oh
they came for the same name she's still
grace yeah
wow that's that's crazy original guy's a
freak
he's a creepy freak what was the extent
of their relationship because if it's
just this one girl he went on a date
with in the 60s
and it's designed a whole robot after
her but it was his wife it's still weird
either way
oh the sweets
i heard three new tall white blonde guys
just
[Laughter]
jesus is strangely known for a month
which we love her
oh no oh
it's cool if they chose like violet
music for uh
no i mean they would but i don't want
them don't kill the kid
don't have to commit suicide maybe just
threw it in there are you gonna moses
this this [ __ ] lake so she knows
about her powers
and then she's gonna see her whoo
tanya oh
god jesus save that boy how did he drown
so fast that was yeah that was hella
quick that's not how drowning works you
can pull the water out of him
you can water bend it pull the water out
man
holy [ __ ] they just kill the [ __ ]
this kid just killed himself
wow
[Applause]
what just breathe life into this
[ __ ] oh
what the [ __ ] did you give that power
did she no that kid was dead and she
definitely
should do to him she'd definitely
breathe life into him
luther
oh i have a feeling it's gonna happen
[Music]
um
doing it hell yeah oh they went there
oh whoa
get it vanya rub
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh why it was cut away damn umbrella
academy
[Laughter]
she's gonna use those calluses
no clousy no no as they all start coming
together
things just start falling apart in some
ways
man this feels very real
he did the nitrous
oh who's gonna [ __ ] this time
[Laughter]
oh don't call him a nape i do
oh no
oh god oh thank god
for my best friend
damn that's [ __ ] up
jesus that's cemented
assassination huh yeah
oh
nice come on five do it
oh oh lily's gonna come in and help help
five
knuckles oh god oh who did she help
oh the one she's assigned to the one
help the man you love keep calling her
lily
oh [ __ ] i'm gonna throw out the window
nice help diego jesus
did not really help diego why would she
not i don't know that makes no sense
that's right come on diego why would she
not help him
oh sweet what a great shot that's the
one dragon shot to the windows the
glimpse oh that's so great
nice back inside
nice
oh come on what did you say
all right so for sure reginald
was somehow mixed in with the jfk
assassination 100
confirmed in that meeting they said it
was like inquiries of roswell other
crash landing sites
he's against it they say the whole thing
about the motorcade turning on elm
street where jfk was shot but he's
saying your timing of this is like
ill-timed it's not clear if he's against
killing the president or if he's just
against the timing of killing the
president but
all this alien conspiracy stuff is tying
back in and it sounds like the
appearances of
roswell all these other alien stuff and
perhaps even the you know alien
appearances of
the umbrella academy children going back
in time are factoring into this as well
i like when the l.a character back at
home base who's hanging out with luther
right now
and he was kind of kicked out of it all
the alien stuff seems to be tying back
into it as well
yeah so all coming they're really doing
the whole 60s
right right yeah conspiracy theories
yeah they're doing it all of it
i think as much for as a a dick as daddy
hargraves can be i feel like maybe
in this is his way of trying to do
something good within the system if he's
trying to kind of delay the
assassination of
jfk or they're trying to stop it we
don't know you have to see how the plot
thickens uh i think they're like maybe
the the alien council
or something yeah yeah they themselves
are aliens because they kind of hinted
at that in the first season that hard
graves is probably not of this earth oh
yeah that's true
oh they themselves could be the
so okay yeah because it's not that the
president is in on the alien conspiracy
stuff it's like the president wants to
uncover this and they're a council who
actually knows about these things
yes because they're not from this world
oh
that could be fascinating that could be
really chosen that is that is my theory
we'll see where this goes but you did
get a lot of cool things in that ball
and in the whole event there i mean the
appearance of grace
i love that she's an actual person yeah
an actual person actual human but man
these guys suck at the time travel thing
yeah they get way too reactionary
they clearly didn't watch enough movies
you can't just go up and say mom class
you can't just go up there and be like
hey i know your whole story i love you
you know you break down history
you guys are just not handling that time
travel scenario that well bonnie took it
pretty well
because bob onions and all these dessert
is handling the chip really well
yeah she's like uh-huh uh-huh how'd the
apocalypse start okay
buys the fact that apocalypse is real
and then rolling with it
luther is exceptionally better this
season he was good in the first season
way better second season but this
character's character i just find
extremely more appealing you can
feel the actor having more fun this
season having more fun having more to do
much more interesting characters much
more compelling yeah more complex i love
what he's doing with the role
you know i love that scene with him high
on the nitrous
yeah dude that was great he's kind of
like drunk on pain right now
yeah that's a good way to put it drunk
on pain him and allison reuniting i love
the way his the
little nuances of comedy that he brought
to the scene work there and also the
visual language of course when they hug
and everyone's disappeared
vanya's powers are just exponential
she's just
broken she's stupid that's like stupid
power crazy
right the kid was dead and she literally
breathed
life into him but the thing i noticed
that when she breathed life into him
that is the same
color the same type of essence that when
it showed the flashback in the season
finale of season one that hargrave is
released into the air
that same kind of look to it sounded
like i wonder if that's kind of
connected and like maybe hard graves did
something
that could come into play or maybe i
don't know if they all have that kind of
essence within them yeah
lila right i keep calling my lily lila
much more interesting character
than initially kind of presented yeah
and i'm i'm very captivated by her and
that was an interesting complex
choice she had to make there yeah of
course it's like of course she would
just immediately choose
five especially at this early in season
two yeah she's going to you know
yeah but i do think she's gonna i think
they're setting her up at least the show
could surprise me but i think they're
sending her up to ark into being it you
know someone who's actually part of the
right team
yeah and helping out to be a hero i
think that the good thing this season is
doing is
though we did have characters we're
really connected to in life in season
one yes those characters aren't here or
at least in the same way this season but
they're doing a great job of presenting
new characters that are
that are likable in different ways yeah
lila and then the
the guy at the building who luther was
getting high with i got that first name
right now it's elliott
elliott yeah introducing characters like
um like raymond
i feel like they're doing a really great
job of giving us new side characters
that we can kind of connect to
it's funny how raymond's reasoning
before we just couldn't get it yeah
we're like what
come on now and then when you hear what
he's saying it is like
oh yeah if your first thought isn't you
have superpowers this is probably the
most logical
next thought you would go to you're
undercover you're walking with the man
yeah you're helping out the man they're
paying you out so that way they can stop
you guys yeah
i i actually totally buy where he's
coming especially without getting any
clear-cut answers and why people just
showing up
i totally get where he's coming from
there good job show for justifying good
job
show it's almost as if you have a solid
team of writers
on hand it's like you have people that
can capture perspective
in terms of like characters who i'm not
sure how i feel about this
[ __ ] i don't know why i'm getting the
feeling that they're gonna do something
like super
with her or i don't know what it is
superpowers i don't know why i'm getting
this impression
i just feel like they're going there but
then again it could be a little too
repetitive
she could just be the nicest woman on
earth
well leading up into the conversation
right before they started kissing what i
loved about what she was saying
was the relatability of the human
emotion on that because
her experiences that [ __ ] is strictly
drawing from
are completely different than vanya's
but the emotions that are generated
from her experiences and circumstances
are similar
that's what i loved about that exchange
of dialogue so leading into the kiss was
actually a really
moving moment at the time if something
tragic doesn't happen
to [ __ ] by the end of the season do you
think that
giving her this partner is a way of them
getting her off of the show so they can
give vania a happy ending like they
leave her in the 60s once they
once they solve oh that's your chance to
say yeah um
maybe they could yeah
i didn't think about that that's a very
big possibility you know you brought a
really good thing that i completely
forgot about
when luther and alison were together
what the [ __ ] going on allison's kid
yeah i totally forgot about her like she
has zero concern for the kid
yeah and that was like her whole thing
in season yeah that was all that was
her main character trait like here's why
you should care about allison
my daughter my daughter did i mention
that i have a daughter
yeah i haven't even heard a peep about
it not a single word not even a mention
of her name who knows maybe it'll come
up later
like toss it in there the apocalypse
occurred
yeah the apocalypse happened she's dead
detect yeah
but you'd still expect something of a
conversation to be uh
erupted for this heartbreak of that yeah
like the morning of the loss of her
daughter so surprising what did you
think of
grayson here i thought it was
fascinating how she's a completely
different type of human because
obviously she's a robot who was
programmed in the first season to be a
very specific way
i thought it was interesting she has a
she's a real person she has a southern
accent raises a lot of questions within
me are like okay
is this just some girl he went on one
date with in the 60s or did this woman
eventually become his wife who we lost
yeah because i feel like that kind of
changes the context
behind his creation of the android
grace it makes me wonder like well in
season one the reasoning they created
grace was so
vani could have a nanny because she
would kill all the other nannies yeah so
i'm like
was this something that he was planning
the whole time or was this like a backup
plan
i don't know but was she did she die and
then he just preserved her body
epidermis yeah that'd be really weird
either way because i thought it might be
something of oh the real life grace
represented the kind of qualities that
you would uh that a a proper android
would need in order to take care of anya
but then you see this grace personality
currently and like
it doesn't seem like the caretaking type
yeah i'm glad we only saw like one
or two scenes with her so we don't know
her full personality we just know her or
maybe it's just a cool thing the show's
doing
just like having a real grace in here
yeah it could just be that
honestly yeah and i think the way
they're keeping the mystery
of reginald is really impressive because
when you think about season one you
spend a lot of time with reginald and
these flashbacks and such you really
don't know reginald they don't show him
as a character they show
the children's perspective on their
father yeah so then when you're seeing
reginald now
there is a lot of mystery to unpack with
his character
it's not just show up and info dump hey
we're your children you have to figure
out who he is now and what he's up to
now and what other secrets you have to
uncover about him
in order for him to help out but it
seems like he's going to play an actual
pivotal part in helping to save the day
the way
this this season so far is kind of
unpackaging information is very well
done i will say that it leaves you
asking questions but it also gives you
answers in a way that you wouldn't
expect them to
yeah for example last season or not last
season last episode or episodes prior we
were kind of asking like well how's
klaus been doing
like the drug situation you know with
him being the 60s then last episode
though he said dicks drugs and
something else and this this episode ben
was like hey
you've been sober for three years don't
mess it up for one day and then
granted he does end up breaking his
sobriety yeah it was very
very interesting but yeah they kind of
addressed that question that we had at
the beginning that whole thing with
david was
that's so sad i mean he's not there's a
lot that he's not factoring in of the
pressure
basic psychology to be honest yeah
psychology how people work
you know like this he hasn't gone to war
yet you're dumping a lot on him and it's
like you gotta
kind of put yourself in his shoes a
little bit i i can't help but get like a
little bit hurt
by like come on klaus you're doing
you're going about this in the complete
wrong fashion
frustrating i know you're desperate to
save him but come on man
you know come on there's a billion other
ways you could have gone about this
that's twice this episode he's not the
best at like convincing people because
he the story with the scorpion and the
frog
yeah i was like i don't know that story
but i can tell like that's not
probably how that goes it's flying off
the handle and i feel like
the the focus on klaus has been a little
bit weird
i'm not sure what they're really doing
with klaus this season
yeah i don't know the whole thing with
klaus last season seemed a lot more
specific and like yeah he's a guy who's
a drug addict and then through this
journey he will start recovering and
learning to embrace and accept himself
and i'm not really sure what the journey
is with him
this time around yeah it seems i feel
like the show knows yeah i just
i just don't know he's more personal
because we saw him go from like this
dude who's kind of wandering
to a cult leader and then i think his
focus and objective
in this season is to get david to kind
of not go into that life
but we have yet to see his sort of
connection in relation to
the grander apocalyp as a whole but you
know he's going to be involved oh of
course
because of the it's got to be the
opening scene
it's over again he's going to save the
day and another thing too is like with
diego i love what they've been doing
with him with this lilac character being
infused to add that extra layer
especially with her upbringing i'm like
she's she's she seems like she's on the
trajectory to being on the right side
her parents were murdered by the bureau
essentially and now
she's working for them and she's been
gaslighted manipulated this whole time
programmed
programmed and now she has to break her
programming and i think with her finding
with like unveiling the truth to someone
whether it be five or diego could be an
interesting character arc for her
actually the scene where he confronts
grace and then he goes nice to meet you
i think does put a bit of a closure
stamp on that whole journey he had with
his
mom essentially like there's a big part
of season one of like he's trying to
connect with her no she actually feels
and trying to deal with the fact that
not she's just an android does she have
actual emotions or not and i'm not sure
what interpretation i'm supposed to take
from the whole thing with nice to meet
you
i feel like in some way there's it's
putting a bit of an acceptance and
understanding on
who he was actually raised by and and
cared for by
interesting interesting yeah
[Laughter]
oh yeah he's gotta be pissed there like
why'd you help five
you sleeping with five
a little boy yeah i think it's uh
it's coming together nicely the whole
show is coming together really well all
right guys well what'd you think of this
episode
subscribe hit that notification bell
check us out on patreon follow her on
instagram
last but not least
niraj krishnan how you doing niraj
razz algool i love
this man when i responded to your last
message my dude
you said that lately during this time of
quarantining
you've actually been trying out of
finding a lot of delicious
south indian food and you said a lot of
it is vegan friendly
i'm waiting to hear back from you
because i'm pescatarian
my woman who occasionally hugs me that i
call a girlfriend
she's vegetarian and i could use
some good vegan indian recommendations
we got like nine restaurants around us
so
i'm waiting to hear back from you dude
and if you don't get back to me sooner
than later i'm gonna have to block you
on youtube
not on patreon oh no no not a petrol can
i'll lose
but it's free to be a part of our
youtube channel so
yeah i'll block you that's my threat
it's a penance really
it's tithe one way to get yourself
unblocked on youtube would be uh
is my sister's birthday this past week
and she really wants some indian food
this weekend
so uh you know you could just kill two
birds one stone
don't be racist south indian food i'm
sorry we were racist
dude just cause he's indian you're going
to talk to him about indian food i
thought that's the one thing that indian
people know about
i'm so sorry i'm so i'm i'm so sorry am
i
am i being racist by associating a group
of people with only
one fascination i'm not sorry sorry to
sit in a rush i'm sorry to you
oh because thank you raj only does know
about indian food unfortunately in songs
so i wish he could help you out more
damn you narage
god man you're killing me over here oh
my god look at you're stressing us
out what are you doing
you